also welche reaktion ist verhältnismäßig
auf diese corona krise dass auch hier in
der redaktion tief umstritten darüber
haben wir wie gesagt heute nachmittag
hier gestritten mit alice von schönburg
und bettina kochheim aber wir sehen
drastische folgen jetzt für die
wirtschaft nicht nur in deutschland
sondern international hinter mir die
kurve des dow jones heute und wir sehen
das ist die entscheidende zahl minus 6,2
423 aktuell
der börsenindex in den usa und auch
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit markus
koch dem börsenexperten live
zugeschaltet aus frankfurt hallo markus
eine frage bevor wir schnell wieder
zurück nach nordrhein-westfalen nach
heinsberg gehen wo aktuell über den
todesfall informiert wird markus ist das
meiner meinung nach wenn du diese zahlen
hier hinter mir sie ist verhältnismäßig
wie im moment reagiert wird weltweit auf
diese corona krise ja absolut also wir
sehen dass wir zuerst natürlich einen
massiven ausfall im angebot hatten die
lieferketten wurden gebrochenen china
und jetzt sehen wir natürlich genau das
was wir durch angst auch bekommen wir
sehen einen nachfrageschock deshalb ist
der vergleich mit dem elften september
den ich persönlich miterlebt habe dort
auch durchaus nicht ganz falsch und dass
die saudia dass die saudis jetzt am
wochenende den ölpreis rapide abgewertet
haben
das hilft natürlich auch nicht also die
wirtschaft ist angeschlagen und ist es
sehr wahrscheinlich dass wir eine
rezession in deutschland wahrscheinlich
schon haben und auch in amerika bald
eine folgen wird wenn wir diese
drastischen folgen weltweit sehen lasst
uns doch einmal über verhältnismäßigkeit
sprechen du hast gerade schon über die
korona angst gesprochen ist das eine
hysterie die möglicherweise viel zu
große sind deinen augen die solche
drastischen folgen eben auslöst nun ich
erinnere an ein altes zitat von ftr dem
amerikanischen präsidenten vor langer
langer zeit der damals schon gesagt hat
fürchten nichts mehr als die furcht
selbst und von daher müssen wir schon
aufpassen dass wir uns bei diesem
nachfrageschock nicht wirklich um kopf
und kragen reden wie sinnvoll ist es
wirklich jeden einzelnen fall zu melden
nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich auch
wichtig zu sehen wann der cenit dieser
erkrankungen erreicht ist und wir an der
börse schauen natürlich auf die daten
die vorhanden sind die vorliegen in
china sehen wir selbst wenn man den
daten aus china nicht traut man war die
satelliten aufnahmen anschaut vom
verkehrsaufkommen von der
umweltverschmutzung sensibel in china
eine zunehmende normalisierung selbst in
südkorea sehen wir eine deutliche
normalisierung und wenn wir einen
ähnlichen trend bekommen wie in italien
dann müssten wir in deutschland in
spätestens zwei drei wochen den zenit
bei der geschwindigkeit der infizierung
sehen in den usa frühestens allerdings
und etwa ein bis zwei monaten
das heißt du hast ja gerade parallelen
gezogen zudem elfter september und den
auswirkungen auf die börsen auf die
wirtschaft weltweit jetzt sagst du ja
vielleicht zwei drei wochen und dann ist
der zenit erreicht das heißt du stellt
sich jetzt nicht darauf ein dass das
eine monatelange wirtschaftsschwäche
sein wird doch und das ist eben genau
der punkt denn selbst wenn dieser zenit
erreicht ist dauert es natürlich sehr
lange bis das alles durch die systeme
filtert ein ausfall der lieferketten
wird sich nicht auf ein quartal
fokussieren sondern das läuft über
einige quartale bis wir eine
normalisierung sehen erpo sieht das
jetzt bei den iphone-verkäufen zum
beispiel auch in china und der
nachfrageschock auch den wird man nicht
über nacht erhellen können die tatsache
dass jetzt auch noch der ölpreis
einbricht auch das erhöht die gefahr
einer rezession
es ist ein langer prozess und genau das
preis die börse ein die börse ist ein
sehr guter mechanismus um zu sehen wie
die wirtschaft reagieren wird was uns
die börsenkurse sagen ist wir kriegen
eine rezession und es wird sehr wichtig
sein das genauso wie nach der
finanzkrise das entschieden gehandelt
wird in amerika kann dass die notenbank
machen donald trump könnte auch ein
moratorium auf den handelskrieg mit
china ausrufen in europa ist der tank
der ezb relativ leer
hier ist vor allen dingen die politik
gefordert fiskalmaßnahmen ins leben zu
rufen
es gab ja die sitzung des
koalitionsausschusses in der vergangenen
nacht bis tief in die nacht nämlich
nachts um 2 markus du bist ja im moment
in deutschland hast das vermutlich
intensiv verfolgt ist das so eine
entschlossene reaktion heute der
bundesregierung gewesen und wenn nicht
was geht da noch was müsste seiner
meinung nach kommen die tatsache ist
leider gottes aus der amerikanischen
perspektive und ich lebe seit fast 30
jahren in den usa das europa eben sehr
guter wenn es lange zu diskutieren viele
ausschüsse ins leben zu rufen und wenn
der patient gestorben ist dann reagiert
man sowas nach der finanzkrise dem
amerikanischen bankensystem geht heute
gut dass europäische liegt immer noch am
boden die amerikaner konnten auch die
zinsen wieder anheben die ezb war nie
wirklich in der lage dazu wir müssen
auch jetzt aufpassen dass wir
entschieden vorgehen gerade deutschland
hat bei der fiskalpolitik die
möglichkeit gas zu geben sondersituation
steuersenkung zu machen ihr
infrastrukturinvestitionen zu machen
gezielt unternehmen zu entlassen
wir entlasten die der punkt ist nur der
es muss schnell gehandelt werden es geht
hier nicht um sechs monate oder zwölf
monate eigentlich müsste schon jetzt die
entscheidung fallen sofort einzugreifen
so weit sind wir hier noch nicht es gibt
ja zuerst überbrückungskredite oder
überlegungen dafür und so weiter und so
fort wir haben heute früh aber auch
hierbei gilt ein unternehmer gehört der
schon viel viel weiter ist er nämlich
vergangene woche schon die ersten
befristeten arbeitsplätze kündigen
musste und wahrscheinlich weitere
arbeitsplätze es war ein unternehmer aus
der veranstaltungstechnik diese woche
noch wird streichen müssen wenn du das
hörst hast du schon ein gefühl oder
möglicherweise auch daten für eine
größenordnung inwieweit das corona virus
hier arbeitsplätze in deutschland kosten
könnte nun das problem ist natürlich
dass die europäische wirtschaft ja
ohnehin schon angeschlagen war schon vor
dem corona virus und insbesondere auch
die verarbeitende industrie und die
autobauer also das rückgrat der
deutschen wirtschaft
und china ist einer der größten
absatzmärkte wenn man sich dort die
einbrüche der autoverkäufer anschaut
steigen einem wirklich die tränen in die
augen
wir reden hier nicht von zehn prozent 20
prozent wir reden von 90 prozent im
januar und februar dann 60 prozent jetzt
in diesem monat das ist eine harte
nummer
wie groß jetzt das ausmaß genau sein
wird ist schwer abzuschätzen aber fest
steht dass in
die situation kurzfristig gerade wegen
der un wegen der starken abhängigkeit an
china vehement größer ausfallen wird als
die usa für die usa ist china wichtig
aber für deutschland ist china
viel wichtiger